aussitôt arrivé aussitôt reparti cette
camionnette transportent des demandeurs
d'asile fraîchement débarqué au royaume
uni direction l'aéroport il doit être
emmené au rwanda sur un vol nolisé sauf
qu est la tombée de la nuit l'avion est
toujours là à la dernière minute la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme empêche
la déportation des passagers cloués au
sol la nouvelle politique migratoire
britannique a du plomb dans l aile
en vertu d'un accord inusité signé en
avril londres a convenu d'envoyer au
rwanda les migrants qui y entrent sur
son territoire de façon irrégulière
l'objectif est de dissuader ceux qui
prennent la mer pour gagner les côtes
britanniques ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à le faire en fait depuis le
début de l'année plus de dix mille
personnes surtout du moyen orient et du
nord de l'afrique ont atteint l'europe
puis traverser la manche jusqu'au
royaume uni elles pourront maintenant
être expulsé à 6000 km de là we believe
de
disques rouleront
dix 10 ans parmi ceux qui s'insurgent
contre cet accord le haut commissaire de
l'onu pour les réfugiés estime que le
droit d'asile est un principe
humanitaire fondamentale et qu'on ne
peut pas le sous traiter deux précédents
disques reid
fait
d'ailleurs plusieurs centaines de
manifestants se sont rassemblés devant
le ministère de l'intérieur à londres
pour protester eux aussi contre la
politique du gouvernement britannique
notre pays dit elle a les ressources
nécessaires pour prendre soin de ces
gens la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme leur donne donc une victoire
provisoire aucune expulsion ne pourra
avoir lieu jusqu'à ce que le projet de
loi soit étudié par la justice
britannique le mois prochain
boris johnson demeure imperturbable
convaincu que la stratégie permettra
d'endiguer le flot de réfugiés
le gouvernement rwandais promet quant à
lui que ceux qui arrivent seront en
sécurité
c'est dans cette auberge de kigali
construite en 2014 pour accueillir des
réfugiés du génocide que s'installera le
premier groupe de demandeurs d'asile du
royaume uni laurent accepté parce que il
faut
et c'est de trouver une solution à ce
problème qui dure depuis longtemps un
problème qui prend les vies des gens en
traversant le désert en soins dans la
mer méditerranée en devenant victimes de
trafic des êtres humains le rwanda
obtiendra également une compensation de
190 millions de dollars de la part de
londres pour les cinq prochaines années
pourvu bien sûr que l'accord prenne son
envol ici sébastien et desrosiers radio
canada morin